well this story certainly grabbed my
attention because
it revolves working around in a barefoot
way
in a warm tropical place insider reports
that a luxury hotel in the
maldives those beautiful little islands
that look like they're not real
yeah they're looking for a barefoot
bookseller to run its
in-house bookshop the island resort is
taking applications
online right now and the job starts
later this month
so i mean come on are you kidding me
this sounds like a dream if you love
books and travel
and you don't want to wear shoes and
your navel nasal swab comes out negative
go get your dream job
okay it's going to be on our website how
to like find that
next up if you're anything like me and
you just can't get
i can't get enough of organizational
guru
and womanize stalk and i've never heard
back from marie kondo
and her enviable tithing skills really i
talk about her all the time
haven't heard i think i scared her away
but marie
um anyway marie you recently launched an
online tidying course konmari method
fundamentals of tidying
i'm all over it according to
entrepreneur.com there is a 10-part
course
that expands on the philosophy behind
marie's methods and are really helpful
for people who prefer learning through
visual demonstrations
i have to tell you i always say it marie
you have changed my life
and the reason i joke around about how
crazy i am for you is because
you have opened my eyes your spark
joy question the way that you handle
human beings
your stuff is not just about
organization it's about humanity
and i really do hold you in the highest
regard so
it's it's it's good intentions and you
spark joy in my world
all the time so moving on i'm trying to
bring her back in and ingratiate her
because i love her so much
i do i mean i can we try calling her is
it weird it's getting weird
anyway okay it is time for some
halloweeny
food news
last halloween americans spent 2.6
billion dollars on candy and this year
even with covet experts estimate that at
least 2.4 billion will happen in sales
so what are people buying we had to know
and it turns out real
simple they reported on an interactive
map
made by thecandystore.com that reveals
the most
popular candy in every state all right
i had to just devour this right here in
new york the top three are
candy corn hot tamales
and sour patch kids these are my girl's
favorite actually it's so funny
i literally was talking to them last
night and i was like what's your
favorite candy
i just did a hot tamale oh my god those
are so good oh
really sticky over minnesota
it's skittles and then tootsie pops and
almond joy because sometimes you feel
like a nut
sometimes you don't and in hawaii they
love their
hershey's kisses hawaiian oats
and milky ways i'm sorry
okay there we go now let's branch out
with one of our vff's about their top
candy pics in none other than illinois
hi vanessa
hi drew so it's nice to meet you
oh it's so nice to meet you too vanessa
what do they
love in illinois they love
kit kats in illinois that's our number
one candy out here
and fun fact it's a hershey product and
my dad used to work for hershey
really what did he do there may i ask
you know he um
he worked on these things called change
makers that actually were put
in grocery stores so people could get
little you know penny candies out of
there
um but other where in the world kit kats
are nestle products so fun fact
oh i love that and that jingle will get
in your head for days
those kids got people they really nailed
it you're like
it's in there for the rest of the
afternoon well thank you vanessa so much
i don't know why
i'm going for the sour patch kids
because they're reminding me of my girls
and i need to stop
thank you so much for stopping by oopsie
oh dear and finally we have a truly
inspiring story
out of dallas texas an 81 year old great
grandmother
has decided to use quarantine to pursue
one of her longtime dreams
and she's going back to school and she
just kicked off her fall semester at
harvard yeah
yeah and now she's going to tell us how
it's going please welcome barbara ingram
hello hi
thank you it's good to be here oh my
gosh
thank you so much for coming on the show
may i ask
what inspired you to do this was there a
subject was there something in life
something you felt you missed out on
what was the impetus
well you know you could sit around for
so long doing
during our virus that we've had here and
you can watch so much tv
and you can read so much and and i was
getting a little depressed and bored and
so i thought you know what i just
i want to go back to school but i think
you know my family will think i'm crazy
to mention it to them but when i
mentioned it to them
they they were very supportive and said
you go
for it and so i um i
applied and and and went but um
i just feel that you know
being physical is great and doing
physical things to stay in shape
at my age is great but some of us can't
do it due to
bad knees bad hips etc and so
but i think it's even more important for
us to stay mentally
stimulated and this is what i wanted to
do
okay first of all really quickly
what subjects are you tackling
economics can i ask you a burning
question which
i don't know if anyone else is having
but i certainly am is harvard as hard as
i would be afraid it was
i do study every day two to three hours
and it is
yes it is hard but i'm up for the
challenge
thank you barbara you're amazing thank
you for being on the show
thank you so much for inviting me and
stay safe